(water lapping)
(tranquil music)
- When we first started measuring ice
back in the early 1990s,
nobody knew basically
what Greenland was doing.
Was it getting bigger or getting smaller?
That was a total unknown.
And so, in 2000, we
published our first results,
using an older version of the technology
that we're using now in Ice Bridge.
And what that showed us
was that the ice sheet
was not in balance.
It was delivering ice into the
oceans and raising sea level,
even at that time, and that
process has accelerated.
It's retreated kilometers since that time.
At, I think it's fair to
say: an alarming rate.
- Ice sheets are like bathtubs
full of water, essentially.
And so if you take the plug out,
then, it's gonna go into the
ocean and sea levels will rise.
(tranquil music)
- The majority of the
people of North America
live on the shoreline.
You go to European continent, the same.
South America, the same.
That means majority of where people live
will be afflicted by the change.
If we are true believers in spirit,
we cannot just watch them drown.
(spacey musical theme)
- Whoa! (laughing)
I give up.
I surrender.
We are at the terminus of Russel Glacier,
of the Greenland ice sheet.
And so what we're standing
in front of, right here,
is where, essentially, the
glacier comes to an end.
So, you can see it's melting,
you can hear it, actually.
You can see the icicles hanging
from the front of the cliff,
which indicates that the melt has started,
and you can hear the ice
kind of cracking and popping,
which means that it's actively
breaking off and falling.
It's a dynamic landscape, as you can see.
Things are falling, you
can hear liquid water.
I mean, this is just a
changing, evolving landscape,
and you can visibly see that.
It's like, if, I don't wanna leave. (laughing)
I wanna stay here.
Um, it's just beyond words.
I went to a very small liberal
arts school in Vermont,
and I think I applied to like
15 different grad schools,
because I had no idea what I wanted to do.
And I ended up going from
Vermont all the way to Oregon.
And I'd never seen a glacier
before, until I went to Oregon.
And I just was, I fell in love.
I absolutely fell in love,
and I don't even know
if I can necessarily say
what it was about them,
but the landscape was so
different and dramatic.
To me, it's a very moving landscape,
and it truly touched me
as it pretty much directed
my career choice in life, so, yeah.
It was love at first
sight, I guess. (laughing)
(muttering)
- A couple of days ago, she was
like, shoving it in my face.
Like: open this!
- That's totally exaggerated, by the way.
If you're coming to a place like this,
you have to be a person that
gets along with other people
and is super friendly and outgoing.
Because if you come here
and you're not like that,
then you're probably gonna be miserable
and never come back again.
- Woo!
(acoustic strumming)
- I've eaten more meals
with some of the folks here
that I'm in the field
with than I have with the
other most important people
in my life, back home.
(laughing)
We spend 16 hours a day
together, most days.
You can't spend that kind
of time with each other
and not basically become a family.
We're a long ways from our families.
We're a long ways from
our logistical trains.
We're a long ways from most things,
and so we have to depend on each other,
and ultimately, for me,
that becomes probably
the most rewarding part of this whole job,
is getting to work with such a great team.
(overlapping conversations)
(dogs barking)
(muttering)
(laughing)
- [Man's Voice] So good.
So good.
I love it.
- Well, here we are.
Welcome to Greenland.
(sweeping ambient music)
- [Brooke] Some snacks for the plane.
(sonorous music)
(engines whining)
- [Man On Radio] Okay, sounds good.
So, that's coherent noise, right?
(muttering)
(tranquil music)
(muttering on radio)
- Having the chance to
actually see the ice,
it connects you to it.
It's sort of an inspirational thing,
from a scientific standpoint,
to be able to look at
something that you've been,
you know, building your career off of
and looking at how beautiful it is.
(uptempo music)
And you lose that
inspiration when you're just
working at a computer all day.
- [Man On Radio] Right turn
25 miles, copy, thanks.
- [Brooke] Hey Aaron, any
plan to go back to the dump
to pick up that bench?
- I could use a new bed. (laughing)
You can't blame me if it breaks, John.
- Operation IceBridge is a NASA program
meant to fill in knowledge
about the Earth's cryosphere.
The Earth's ice cover.
The idea is we're trying to measure
everything about the ice,
from the top of the ice,
all the way down to where
it meets the bedrock.
And why would we wanna do that?
Well, the top of the ice
is about taking a snapshot
of what the state of the
Earth's ice cover is now.
And how that compares to
how it was in prior years.
But in order to understand those changes,
we have to put them in context.
- Most people would be very disappointed
if they were plopped in
the middle of an ice sheet,
well, for many reasons, they
would be disappointed, but if
you're plopped in the middle
of an ice sheet, it's flat
and white and boring, and
it's just covered in snow.
But the interesting part
is when you have a radar
that you can actually
see internal horizons,
underneath the surface, and
you can use those internal
horizons to actually
look back through time.
So it's sort of like tree rings.
Basically, the ice sheet
is its own time capsule.
You can go back in time and
understand how it's changing.
If you get more snowfall
than ice mass lost,
then the ice sheet is growing,
but if you get less
snowfall than ice mass loss,
then it's shrinking.
And so it's a key
ingredient in understanding
the glacier's contribution
to sea level rise.
(murmuring on radio)
- Generally, I'm like
a little kid out here.
I get to play around with computers,
and lasers, and airplanes and weather.
And we fly this airplane at
1,500 feet above the surface.
So there are many, many,
many times where we are down
in a glacier valley, collecting
detailed measurements
of that glacier, and the
walls of the canyon are
way above us on both
sides of the airplane.
It is spectacular to be flying that way.
Every day, that's the view
from our office window,
that hardly anybody ever gets to see.
And anybody, anywhere in the world,
regardless of their nationality,
can access our data,
as long as they have
an internet connection.
My hope is that that
open data policy leads
to a better world.
But knowledge of the Earth's
cryosphere is, frankly,
in its infancy right now, in my opinion.
And we have a long way to
go to really understand
what's going on up here.
- [Man On Radio] Okay, let's
debrief starting with ATM.
- [Man On Radio] Okay,
had a great day today.
Weather cooperated.
Our data volume's T-5.
Collected 31 gigabytes.
T-6, collected 162 gigabytes.
Cambot, 52.
(melancholy music)
- I'm lucky today.
I don't know how people
would study ice in the '50s.
What did you, go to the ice and,
you know, make a measurement, dig a hole,
and then come back?
I mean, how are you supposed
to make an inference
about the entire ice sheet,
just from that one data point?
Mainly, people thought that
these ice sheets responded
on such long timescales
that they would never
be able to change anything,
to actually impact
the ice sheets enough that would cause
a visible change over human timescales.
With the advent of
satellites, they opened a lot
of people's eyes to, whoa,
these actually are changing
on timescales that we can understand.
And so that was a big difference.
Because for a while it was:
oh, I study an ice sheet.
And it changes over thousands of years.
But now it's like,
whoa, these can actually
have dramatic changes right now,
and we can see them and it can
impact, basically, everyone.
(rumbling)
- [Female Reporter] Devastation
of Katrina, catastrophic.
- [Male Reporter] 30 people dead
in one apartment complex alone.
(overlapping shouts)
- [Male Reporter] Hundreds
of houses trashed,
as the ocean crashed on through.
- [Male Reporter] Hurricane
Harvey slammed ashore
Friday night as a category four.
- Do not come back to
the evacuation zones.
It has just begun, and
it's going to get worse.
- It's hard to get people
excited about ice sheets
when you tell them, oh,
they're contributing
a millimeter per year to sea level,
and it's a hard number to tell people.
So, you know, you think: this much?
You know, how is that going to matter?
But it's the impact of
storms that gets magnified
once you have an additional
millimeter, that can then impact
a much larger area if
you have a massive storm.
We're pushing the extreme.
So we're getting more extreme storms,
and then if we have rising
seas to go along with it,
that means the impact is just
gonna be more widespread.
Rising sea level is going
to displace a lot of people,
and typically it's a lot of
the people who, financially,
don't have the means to
necessarily to move from where
they've grown up their entire lives.
(morose music)
(wind howling)
(sonorous music)
- In the month of June in 1975,
my mother and father,
instructed me that I should tell the world
that this big ice is melting.
We knew that it was melting
because here on this,
the water was coming out in
1963, in the month of January.
Now, you can see it's nothing.
From being 1,500 meters.
And I spoke about that
at the United Nations,
in the August of 1978.
That was the first time it was brought out
by the native people that
the big ice is melting.
I began to be invited by
organizations and events,
and ended up traveling
for the United Nations
all over the world.
- Do I look like George Clooney,
or Brad Pitt?
- [Woman's Voice] Definitely George.
- You have good taste.
I am friends with many, many people now.
And really look forward
to going to that city,
where the next meeting is going to be.
And we will look forward
to go to a restaurant
and have a nice time, and at the end,
I realized that I was
just like everybody else.
I wasn't changing as I had been
asked by my elders to change
and now it is too late to
stop the melting of the ice.
The idea is to change the
people, and I failed in my work.
So I decided I would quit that job.
I was going home to Nook,
where my mother lived.
(pensive music)
Welcome home.
(vocalizing)
My mother was sitting
in my father's chair.
We took our hands together,
she closed her eyes.
She said: Son, you're
just gonna have to learn
to melt the ice in the heart of man.
Only by melting the ice
in the heart of man,
man will have a chance to change.
And I can still hear her saying that.
I did not succeed,
because I failed to change
the leadership of the world.
We still talk about the same old stuff.
For the last 40 years,
they've been trying to get
to an agreement.
No matter what we do, we
cannot stop the melting
of the big ice; we cannot.
But politically, we
refuse to talk about it.
Because it's just too overwhelming.
And… we will scare the people.
I'd rather scare the
people and wake them up
than let them drown in ignorance.
(plane engines buzzing)
- Bye, IceBridge.
Go forth and science,
IceBridge. (laughing)
The slice of time that we
live in, our Earth looks
like this because of how
big the ice sheets are.
If they weren't there,
our planet would look
entirely different, because all that water
would be in the ocean.
Just keep that in mind.
That, as these start to change,
our planet, as a whole,
will start to change, so.
- There's really only one
place for that ice to go.
It has to go into the
oceans and raise sea level.
And that's important not
only for the United States
to understand what's gonna
happen to our coastal cities,
but also for places around the world,
because so much of the human
population around the world
lives very close to sea level.
Public policy decisions
will have to be made
to shore up all that infrastructure.
And those public policy
decisions need to be informed
by facts, not by politics, but by facts.
- The only thing we can do
now is to become the hope
for the world in which we live.
You personally, can become the hope
in the world you live in.
So, my prayer is that
one of you will awaken
in this spirit and
become the guiding light
for the people in the world.
The world in which we live needs hope.
That's the greatest need.
(somber music)